all right let's get to the mailbag for
the week info
davidpackman.com uh I don't know if it's
because it's election week or what
happened this week but some really just
like extra wacky stuff came in and of
course you all know I love to address
substantive critiques let's start with a
message from silky about why I'm a
coward and a hypocrite okay silky says
hello Pac-Man Fever da da da I don't
know I saw your recent video where you
watched the fetterman Oz debate and you
really showed your hypocrisy when you
admonished people in your chat for
saying things you didn't like about
fetterman because you hate your audience
um that didn't happen what I said was
the people
overtly making fun of the fact that he
had a stroke
that was in poor taste and I stand by
that
person goes on to say uh mainly
questioning is mental faculties which is
a valid concern okay that's not what
they were doing what's interesting
though right silky is you're constantly
saying similar things about Trump Lake
Marjorie Taylor green and other
conservatives even Tulsi gabbard
questioning their mental state and
health
that is not true
that is not true this is a person who
has not actually listened to what I've
said when it comes to Trump
we have had long time concerns about the
glitching and the twitching and the you
know getting confused about what's
coming out of his mouth saying we need
to look into the oranges of the
investigation and he looks confused and
he can't get the word he wants we've you
know Rudy giuliani's sitting in front of
him and he starts looking around where
is Rudy where's Rudy's three feet away
that's Trump okay
Lake and Marjorie Taylor green
it's a disconnection from reality and a
sort of radicalized ignorance so it's
it's different I've never thought that
Lake and Marjorie Taylor green
we're having cognitive issues I think
they're nuts I think they're dangerous
but in any case this is as usual someone
who is reacting to things I haven't said
and Tulsi I've never talked about Tulsi
in this context and the lastly silky
says and in vain with that
I think you mean in that vein why don't
you invite some of these people onto
your show you do have a large enough
platform if they truly are as mentally
unstable as you constantly claim you
should have no issue debunking their
arguments or making them out to be fools
but you won't because you're a coward
we've invited all of these people they
refuse to come on
I had Ben Shapiro on some years ago it
was fine it didn't go great for him but
it was it was a fine it was hugely
embarrassing he's refused to come back
on ever since
so they are invited and people say David
you criticize Jordan Peterson why not
have him on I've had them on and we've
invited him multiple times he refuses to
come on okay so come on guys try try to
try to just be a little bit more
reasonable in these emails uh Patrick
Rhoden who also writes in as Donna all
the I guess it's Donna writing in as
someone named Patrick I don't know
and uh Donna says Dave you can spin it
any way you want
I live in Upstate New York and oil and
electric prices have tripled and winter
is not even here groceries through the
roof if we don't become energy
independent again it will it will get
worse economically everyone knows that
energy is the heart of our survival so
spin it over and over again I still
listen to you once in a while yet this
is this is someone who just doesn't know
what's happening first of all if you
said to someone
what does it mean to be energy
independent what do you think they would
say I think a lot of people if you said
energy Independence they would say we
domestically produce all of the energy
we use now when Trump has been talking
about energy Independence he's not even
talking about that Trump's talking about
the import export numbers specifically
for oil
that's what Trump is talking about and
in the last couple years of trump as
well as in the first year of Biden the
U.S roughly exported as much oil as we
imported that's what they mean by energy
Independence so two things one it's not
really energy Independence it's talking
about the trade balance on oil
and two it hasn't really changed since
Joe Biden replaced Donald Trump
do you think Donna has any idea about
that I think the answer is no do you
think Donna's mind would be changed if I
presented her with this information or
him if it's Patrick I don't know
I think the answer is clearly no
Mimi wrote in about a free membership
and says hello Mr Pacman good evening
I would love to have a free membership
but can't afford it I'm on a fixed
income I want you to know keep doing
what you're doing keep up the good work
okay
I've said this a hundred times before
Mimi we love you here let me once get on
the record how to get free memberships
okay you can't email me about it you go
to davidpackman.com free membership
there's three fields to put in
first name last name email
you put your name on the list in order
we will give out the free memberships
you'll be notified by email do not email
about the free memberships go to
davidpackman.com free membership they're
available Timothy wrote in about phone
banking this is a really important email
yo David you say phone banking is
important and I agree the problem is
these Democratic committees want you to
do it on their time and on their terms
I've reached out to many different
Democratic committees saying can you
give me a list of Pennsylvania Democrats
or Bucks County Democrats and I'll call
them to get out the vote the reply is
always we don't do it that way anymore
but we do it this way they go on to
explain they meet up on zoom on a
Saturday or Sunday everyone does it
together I don't like this give me a
list of people and I'll call them if I
get done the list I'll come back for
another list I feel like these
Democratic committees are getting in
their own way yeah listen
I am guessing that when it comes to
phone stuff and giving people
information about people's phone numbers
or different things there's probably
some privacy regulations that need to be
adhered to but I agree with you it can
be way too complicated to help I've
heard from a ton of people who say I
wanted to phone bank they told me first
I've got to attain attend two different
training sessions via Zoom at really
inconvenient times
to only get on the list and then I
needed to sign up for a shift I get it
everybody has processes you got to have
a process you got to vet people all of
it
but you're dissuading people from doing
it there are people who would love to
phone bank but they can't do two
training sessions during work hours
to only get to the point where then they
can pick a shift so I I do think
something needs to happen I don't know
what it is but I've heard that from a
lot of people Dan wrote in about Jordan
Peterson and Jordan says why is it that
nobody has pointed out to Jordan
Peterson and others like him that the
justification they use for religion
gender roles Etc are the same as those
for the authoritarian governments he's
literally saying Society doesn't
function properly when people don't fit
into their prescribed role all while
lambasting socialism and communism for
their supposed lack of freedoms not sure
I'm making my point well
but it's really kind of comical if you
follow what I'm getting at I do
a lot of these folks like Jordan
Peterson say
communism and socialism are bad because
they dictate how people should behave
what type of job they should have
all of these different Norms they take
away Freedom which capitalism leaves for
people but on the other hand they are
extraordinarily authoritarian in how
they believe Society should be
prescribing whether it's gender roles or
behavior or whatever the case may be
that's absolutely true if you presented
this to them they would say
Society is just a reflection of what the
people want
whereas a communist or socialist
government is an authoritarian
imposition and I do think that that's
valid the problem is you can get around
that by saying we're not Communists and
socialists we just want to elect people
who will actually do the things we want
them to do and then it is much more
equivalent to saying well Society or
Media or whatever so good luck
explaining that to them uh but it's a
it's a very good point
Shayna wrote in about YouTube and says
hey David I've had a paid membership to
your show for several years but just
realized I'm not actually subscribed to
your YouTube channel I am now just
thought I'd mention it and encourage
other people to check love the show
thanks for your excellent work yes there
are two things going on one
Phantom unsubscribes there are people
who genuinely were at some point
subscribed to YouTube and they report
I'm no longer subscribed I'm not
claiming YouTube is unsubscribing people
could be a glitch could be anything
double check and number two there's tons
of people who see our Clips on their
home page on YouTube so they don't even
think I need to do anything else
hit the Subscribe button it won't really
change anything you're already seeing
our Clips but it is a really big deal
for those subscriber numbers to continue
growing it signals to YouTube to keep
recommending our Clips to more people so
appreciate that very much Shayna Neil
wrote in about something a couple people
called to my attention and said so on
your Discord it was brought to my
attention that your Google profile info
comes up as conspiracy theorist which I
find hilarious considering the time
you've spent dedicated to combating many
conspiracy theories that are harmful and
unsupported one thing to note is Google
pulls this from your Wiki page which
seems to be corrected
but for me and everyone on the Discord
who checked it seemed to be pulling some
old info yeah I I saw this here's what's
going on there is a fight happening on
both my personal Wikipedia page and the
show Wikipedia page essentially with
vandals it's called vandalism on
Wikipedia where they just come through
and because anybody can edit they'll put
in anti-semitic stuff about me or
conspiracy theorist or whatever the case
may be it's mostly caught automatically
and fixed
um but every once in a while like when
it heats up the pages get locked so no
one can edit imagine having such a sad
life that you go around vandalizing
Wikipedia Pages it's it's just it's
really pathetic Mary wrote in about Mike
pillow pillows and says hey David
watched your show about using mic
pillows pillows they are awesome
I've had mine for three years works
wonders for my neck however he's a
complete idiot and I will never buy his
pillows again yeah people have written
in most to be perfectly honest most of
the people who write in say the pillows
are not good
but a couple people like Mary have
written in and said now that the guy's
Bonkers buddy does have a good pillow as
I said during our interview I'm glad to
try my pillow pillows he said he was
sending them to me for me to review them
and that his assistant would reach out
nobody ever reached out I didn't get the
pillows so make of it what you will but
I'm still still waiting still glad to
try them not so concerned that I'm gonna
go buy one myself but if he sends one I
will try it get your emails in info
davidpackman.com we are now into the
post 2022 midterm phase
and it's going to get very very nuts we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and next week we are uh we're hitting
the ground running that's for sure